Prove me wrong.
>> Okay. Then Allah
says
that you guys worship them. They they
were dependent on food.
So Jesus becomes a man and you don't
want him to eat then is he really human?
If he becomes a man and doesn't eat, is
he really human?
>> After that, Allah said,
>> "You didn't answer my question." I know
because that shows Allah doesn't know
logic. So don't embarrass Allah. Just
answer me. If Jesus becomes a real human
being and he doesn't eat food, is he
really human?
>> Yeah, I understand your point.
>> Okay, but now I'm going to turn it
against you. If is Jesus alive in a body
right now according to Sunni Islam that
Allah took him physically, bodily?
>> Yes.
>> So for 2,000 years, he doesn't eat food.
So you just proved he's not human, he's
God.
How do you know Allah does not give him
food?
>> Oh, so you mean there's food with
Allah's presence? So he's feeding a
buffet in the throne. Here you go. Here
you go, Isa. Here you go. Chicken.
Here's here's shish kebab. You serious?
>> You need whatever Jesus.
>> So wait, okay, let's follow. I want to
hear. So Jesus Isa, your Jesus Isa is
with Allah and Allah's giving him
buffet. He's giving him shish kebab.
He's giving him rice, halal food.
>> For 2,000 years, Allah is feeding him
buffet.
>> We don't know how he's living.
>> Go read the say Jesus is now like the
angels. He doesn't eat. That's in your
commentary. Yeah, that's
>> No, he does not eat
>> because they understand if he's with
Allah above the seven heavens, then that
means he won't require food there. That
means he's like the angels who don't
eat.
>> Oh, okay. Then that's how it must be,
you know.
>> So that means you just proved my point.
That means he is either not human
because he's an angel. That's what Kubi
said. [clears throat] Or he is human,
but then he's now a human who doesn't
need food. Because in that state, you
can be human without having to eat. So,
but on this side, on this planet, on
this earth, can you be truly human if
you don't eat?
>> No.
>> So, that's why Jesus ate cuz he's truly
human. But where did you get that?
Because he's truly human and as a human
being he eats, he can't be God. Jesus
didn't say that.
>> Your Quran doesn't say that. Even though
your Quran, your Quran says, it does
say, look, Jesus and Mary ate food. See
how we make their signs clear? No,
that's actually very unclear because the
Quran says Jesus is God's word that
entered Mary. So, it's admitting he is
the word who came down spirit to become
flesh. So, it shows that the eternal
word of Allah can be flesh. But then it
says he ate food. Yeah. What do you
expect him to do?
Just live on oxygen
if he's truly human.
>> Okay, you explain your point. I
understand that. Let's go to the verse
after that. Didn't Allah say he can
neither benefit you nor harm you?
>> Who? He never said that about Jesus.
>> Where does it say that Jesus can neither
benefit you nor harm you? That
contradicts the Quran. How many people
did Jesus benefit when he healed the
blind? He cleansed the lepers. He raised
the dead. Created clay
>> in a divine sense.
>> No, but you're not listening. You just
said Jesus can neither harm nor benefit
you. You're lying because the Quran said
Jesus benefited many people and harmed
many people. those who rejected him? Did
he not benefit the blind by giving them
sight? Did he not benefit the dead by
ris raising them from the dead? Did he
not benefit lepers by cleansing them?
And did he not take clay and create a
bird from clay and breathe into it, blew
into it, and became alive? That sure
sounds like he benefited many people.
>> Those miracles are different.
>> But does that was that benefiting
people? I don't care if it's different.
Did he benefit them?
>> The did blind. So that means either your
Quran is a lie or you're misquing the
verse. It's not about Jesus because
Jesus benefited many people.
>> Oh, you see this is where the problem
is.
>> This is where the problem is.
>> I really pray. Ya Allah guide them.
Guide all.
>> Jesus has guided me. May the eternal son
of God who loves you, who created for
his glory, guide you and open your eyes.
It's time to leave Muhammad. He's done
nothing but destroy life and make people
like you miserable. Jesus is your help.
>> Cried for me. You know that.
>> Say it again.
>> My prophet cried for my forgiveness. You
know that, right?
>> He cried. He I don't think he was crying
for your forgiveness. He was crying for
his own sins because he knows he's in
trouble.
>> Oh, he was saying my um my um
>> You mean that silly hadith that shows
that your prophet is delusional?
that that same hadith proved my prophet
is great.
>> No, it actually proves that your prophet
is delusional. Why? Okay, let me tell
you why. So, you mentioned the hadith.
You're going to in that hadith your
prophet says the day of judgment mankind
will go before the prophets. They'll go
before Adam and ask Adam to intercede.
He'll he'll remember his sin, right? And
he'll say myself, myself. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> And then it says, "Then go to Noah."
They go to Noah and Noah remembers that
he got Allah angry because he said,
"That's my son." When he wasn't a son,
he'll say, "Nevi, my soul, my soul. Go
to Ibraim." They go to Abraham and
Abraham will remember the three times
where he lied or the three sins he
committed. Right? And then he'll say,
"Oh, myself, myself, Nephi, and go to
Moses." And they go to Moses. And then
Moses remember his sin. He murdered
someone saying, "I'm not fit for that.
Nefi myself. Then it says in hadith, go
to Jesus who is the word of Allah
conveyed to Mary a spirit from him. And
when they go to Jesus, the hadith says,
"Your prophet says, and he'll mention no
sin." Moses mentioned his sin. Abraham
mentioned his sin. No mention his sin.
Noah Noah. Adam mentioned his sin. But
it says Jesus mentions no sin. And on
top of that, Jesus will still say, "I'm
not fit for that."
Nefi go to Muhammad and then it says the
one whom Allah has forgiven both his
past and future sins. Can I ask you a
question?
The prophets before Jesus were
disqualified because they committed sin.
In this hadith, your prophet admits
Jesus committed no sin. But then Jesus
says Muhammad's past and future sins
were forgiven. If these other prophets
could not intercede because they were
sinners, how the hell does your prophet
think he's qualified when he's a sinner
and only Jesus is sinless?
>> Do you not know? My prophet said no one
is more god-fearing than me.
>> He's a liar because Jesus is more
God-fearing in the sense that he's
perfect. He's sinless. You don't get
more God-fearing than when you're
absolutely sinless.
>> Oh, don't you know what my prophet said?
Don't you know that your prophet buried
himself because he said Jesus is
sinless? That means there's no one more
god-fearing than one who's sinless.
>> My prophet said the best of sinners are
those who repent.
>> And even better are those who don't need
to repent.
>> OH, REALLY?
>> OH, YEAH. BECAUSE HOLD ON. Are you
saying Gabriel is no good because he
doesn't repent because he doesn't commit
any sin?
>> He is different.
>> No, no, no, no, no, no. It said the best
of sinners are those who repent.
>> Well, sinned, but he didn't repent,
right?
>> Any Muslim?
>> What? He didn't say Muslim. Where did he
say Muslim? He said the best of sinners
are those who repent. So sin, but he
doesn't repent. Gabriel didn't sin. So
who's better? The one who doesn't need
to be forgiven or the one who needs to
be forgiven?
>> How can someone who needs to be
forgiven?
How can someone who needs to be forgiven
be better than the one who doesn't need
forgiveness cuz he's perfect? What are
you talking about?
>> Look, okay, this is what you have to
understand. Listen me out.
>> Okay, I'm listening to you.
>> Allah Allah has so much creation that
worships him. Allah does not need that.
>> Why you change the subject? I'm asking
you who is better. the one who's sinless
and doesn't need forgiveness or the one
who sins and breaks the law and needs to
be forgiven.
>> One hadith Allah said if humans were not
to commit sin, I would avoid
shows Allah is evil. He's going to
destroy perfect people so he can replace
them with sinful people so he can be
merciful. Where's the justice in this?
If I go to a judge, if I go to a judge
and I am sinless and you're filthy and
the judge says, "Because you are
sinless, I'm going to throw you in jail
and kill you because I want someone
wicked so I can then forgive him." What
are you going to say about that judge?
>> Look,
>> what are you going to say about that
judge?
If I am perfect and I've kept the law
perfectly and you broken the law, you're
a murderer and a liar and I give before
the judge and he says, "Yeah, you you
never broke the law, right?" Yeah. You
know what the hell with you? I'm going
to kill you because I just want lawb
breakakers so I can show my justice and
mercy.
>> Oh my god. The way you said the hell
with you was funny, man.
>> Yeah. Well, that's what Allah is going
to do. The hell with perfect people,
right? Because according to the hadith,
Muslim,
>> if we're perfect, wait, don't run away.
I want people to see how evil your god
is.
>> In the hadith, you mentioned Allah said
if there were no sinners on earth, he
would wipe out every man and replace
them with people to sin, right?
>> Not only that, who would sin and then
repent?
>> If people were perfect, he'd wipe them
out, right?
Your hadith says Allah would wipe out
perfect people on earth, right?
>> Yes.
>> Why? Because he wants sinners to sin
who'd repent so he can forgive them,
right?
>> No. Because humans are made.
>> You didn't listen. The hadith says if no
one sinned on earth, he'd wipe them out
and replace them with people to sin so
he can show them mercy. Right? Do I need
to bring the hadith? I know what hadith
you're talking about.
>> But that does not mean every nobody will
not say
>> I didn't ask the question. Does the
hadith say if they were perfect people,
he'd wipe them out?
>> Yes.
>> How is it just to wipe out and perfect
people who've done no wrong? Where's the
justice?
>> There are no people like that. But the
hadith says if they were, he'd wipe them
out anyway. How is that just?
>> If they were, they
>> So why is he saying if they were, he'd
kill them all and wipe them out? Where's
the justice?
>> Allah is showing his mercy that all
>> Where is the justice in wiping out and
killing people who are perfect and have
not done anything worthy of punishment?
>> Allah didn't say he would punish them.
Allah,
>> do you want me to read hadith that says
he'd wipe them out?
>> Yeah, wipe them out does not mean
punishing them.
>> Okay, then what is it? Mercy to wipe out
people who are perfect. No, that's not
punishment. That's that's their reward.
You see how stupid you sound?
Why is he wiping them out? That is not a
reward. That's punishment. Cuz their sin
is they're perfect. So their crime is
they're perfect. Wow, that makes sense.
I think you need to stop now, brother,
because you're embarrassing Allah. Maybe
you can call me next time. We'll talk.
>> I I want to talk about Immi.
>> Okay. You want to talk about him now or
you want to come later? Because you
already spent 40 minutes and you killed
Islam. You actually did a better job of
destroying Islam than me. So, I want to
give you a break. Maybe you can come
tomorrow, God willing.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Can you come tomorrow, God
willing?
>> Points.
>> Yeah. You You did great job. So many
people are going to take Shahad after
this. You're going to have thousands.
Okay, let's do it tomorrow, God willing.
Okay.
>> Okay. I think you are busy right now.
It's
>> No, it's not that. It's already been
four hours, brother and humanity. My
brother in humanity, I pray you'll be my
brother in Jesus. You've already spent
over an hour. I don't want to get people
tired and I don't want to make it
[clears throat] too long because then
people aren't going to watch. Lord
willing, if God wills, we're all live.
You can come tomorrow when I do my live
stream. Coming.